alright this is gonna be one of those
quick ones that I kind of just throw
together I wasn't going to talk about
this but it seems like everybody else's
so i guess i'll throw in my two cents
and that is the first trailer for the
third Hobbit movie Battle of the five
armies is out and it has confirmed
exactly what I knew was going to be the
case which is that this is not Bilbo's
story anymore it was barely Bilbo's
story in the first one it became less
destroying the second one and down the
third one blinking you're going to miss
him in the trailer which just reaffirms
what I said about the desolation of
smaug this is not the hobbit it's taking
the bones of the events of that book but
it's not true to the tone and it
completely sidelines the title character
and when it was announced it was gonna
be three movies I knew that the third
one was gonna focus on the Battle of the
five armies even before the title change
was announced cuz originally was gonna
be called there and back again but the
thing is they are now basing an entire
film around something that has almost
nothing to do with Bilbo I'll put him on
potential spoiler warning on what I'm
about to say but if you've read the
books you know this but if you haven't
minor spoiler warning you've been warned
but in the books Bilbo really doesn't
take part in this battle at all he runs
away effectively he's hiding using the
invisibility of the ring for the first
half and then he gets hit with a rock
and isn't unconscious for the entire
second half of the battle and really the
Battle of the five armies itself is is
one of those weird sort of add ons in a
lot of ways it's like the scouring of
the Shire from the Lord of the Rings in
that at the time that happens the climax
of the story has really kind of already
happened in the case of lord of rings it
was the destruction of the ring in the
case of The Hobbit it's it's dealing
with the dragon that's really the climax
of the story that's what we've been
building toward then that's done and
then there's this other thing that
happens at the end it's thematic
irrelevant it's not necessarily bad
writing but it's a bit of a tack on you
feel like the story's already done but
they're just adding a bit more there was
a reason the scouring of the Shire was
cut and while I'm not necessarily going
to say that the Battle of the five
armies is as superfluous as the scouring
of the Shire it's that same sort of
thing where if they just decided to cut
it all together I would not have
begrudge them that but of course the
Battle of the five armies feels much
more of the epic Lord of the Rings scale
that they
the hobbit to be which of the hobbit was
not supposed to be the Baba was not
intended to be again I'm talking about
the books and what I wanted the movies
to be i am still got to see this thing I
know I am and what I'm gonna try and do
between now and when I actually go and
see the thing is I'm gonna try really
hard to get into the mindset of what
this movie actually is instead of what I
wish it was because the movies not what
i wanted to be it's never going to be
what i wanted to be and I know what it
is so if i can try and get in line with
that except the movie on its own terms
maybe I'll have some fun I don't know if
I'm actually gonna be able to do that
because I like the book too much I guess
sort of the elephant in the room about
the trailer specifically that I'm
avoiding is the use of the song from the
return of the king and while that is an
amazing song as one of my favorite
moments in the trilogy no honestly one
of my favorite pieces of a film
soundtrack ever and it's you still
annoys me because again I I wanted this
movie to feel like it was set in the
same world of Lord of the Rings but I
did not want it to be Lord of the Rings
beta and using that song from such an
iconic movie from Lord of the Rings just
emphasizes that's exactly what it is
though the hobbit the Battle of the five
armies trailer what were your thoughts
are you looking forward to the thing
more less about the same drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
and until next time this council is
adjourned